[Music]
our clients priority is the privacy and
security of the house
this led us to explore design approaches
that fortify but yet will not impede
their enjoyment of this very large
compound an introverted and secure
environment yet spatially and
experientially not limited
nor compressed by this fortification the
challenge was how
we could make a quality family space for
day-to-day living
and home with different spaces for
entertainment parties
and cozy smaller fats within this
protected compound
during the early stage of putting the
plants together
we studied and analyzed the forms of
courtyards in history
and different parts of the world
traditionally
koya houses are symmetrical hierarchical
and highly ordered spaces
the cloister house which is designed
with multiple courtyards
followed a non-hierarchical structure
instead we found that this fluid
structure is very important
for modern families like our clients
since they have young kids
whose lifestyles tend to change over
time this structure also allows the
family to continually adjust
and adapt the spaces within the house
for different uses
from the start we wanted a series of
multiple pitch roofs
instead of a single roof for this single
story deep plan
the initial iteration was a grid of
interconnected
hip roofs terminating with skylights in
their apexes
then we had an aha moment while working
on the model we suddenly flipped the
roofs upside down
and realized that this achieved a couple
of things not only did it scale down the
house by changing the relationship of
the roof
with the interiors the sloping roofs
connect the courtyards to become part of
the living spaces
instead of having skylights that are not
really the most tropical means of
daylighting
the deep interior will be lit ventilated
and
cooled passively with this courtyard
scattered throughout the house
we believe that cloister house
represents a new form of luxury living
in the tropics
it shows how you can still live richly
and have a wealth of experiences within
a single story house
you